thank God it's Friday
Friday
it's funny
greeting is there in periscope fill mad
flavor here checking in with you
[ __ ] to Friday afternoon
most people are the happy hour jumping
up and down [ __ ] them
the only happy hour I got right here my
[ __ ] head
I got a tremendous give me a set of
wheat today I got stars
you know I got delayed nothing tonight
overlaps with my family whoa what the
dinner and I'm gonna be hitting this
[ __ ] boggling every couple of [ __ ]
minutes
here you go [ __ ] look what we
got today fire
look what we got tonight go really you
know I don't need much else
we're here with wit with a beautiful
week to get our goals we cannot
accomplish this now it's another time
for some people for others
two three
four or five
six [ __ ] 50 marks started
that's 725 milligrams a [ __ ]
tremendous THC but it's Friday
[ __ ] if you want to dilly-dally
your buddies have to work too mommy get
up now hang up now
cousin ain't gonna work out for you
what's that look like to you
of a something gorilla glue it's back
[ __ ]
and when it dry out all afternoon I went
to the week school it was 112 degrees
that I went to the [ __ ] gym and left
this at my car [ __ ] cultivate and
getting dry it's beautiful with the
perfect
look at that
you bad [ __ ] aren't you lucky
we live in America that right now you
can get together we uncle Joey
right now I'm [ __ ] periscope and see
the devil just like that it's a
beautiful day to be alive every morning
when you wake up you gotta grab your
balls or salute the [ __ ] flag it's
the greatest country in the world
[ __ ] meanwhile you're walking
around I'm gonna go hiking [ __ ]
Europe what did I blow you to [ __ ] up
over there [ __ ] but everybody
wants the [ __ ] hike Mount Everest me
[ __ ] Mike there's some update you're
gonna die and freeze to death it's not a
[ __ ] movie people were dying and
freezing and crying it'll needs an
aggravation you want to climb something
caught my [ __ ] balcony and sit next
to me a spark up a joint same [ __ ]
difference
if you effective you want adventure I'll
let you climb a building but the Batman
thing let you die there you [ __ ] lose
this is it this is good as it gets
you work all week in hand-to-hand combat
these [ __ ] and then on the
weekends it's all about us look at times
they're chasing people not me I'm in my
family living like a [ __ ] doctor you
understand let's do another movie out of
respect
that's a week
I left the stem in there only [ __ ]
steps and take don't even like
Colombians
I don't like [ __ ] weed snacks
BAM let's get this [ __ ] party spot
and you don't say
breathing in that surgery the surgery
work on Sutton at blue possible out of
both [ __ ] masters like soldier
I love you [ __ ] I love doing
this where you just smoking a bowl just
chillin like this as good as it gets
nobody could purchasing nobody
wake up Donnie Brasco swing world
touchably understand we smoke our weed
we crack all [ __ ] jokes and then we
get together on the road we crack a
couple jokes and we take pictures and
[ __ ] better this
let's go back to another bowl of fire
three bowls and seven stars are you
people whose junk will jump ahead I
might be a [ __ ] I'm not the smartest
dude in the world I'm not the best
[ __ ] committee in the world but I've
got nothing but hard for you
[ __ ] and you know that you
don't know uncle Joey does it take time
take [ __ ] we do it right here
we love everybody
black people Chinese you were sloppy
Armenians I don't give a [ __ ]
there we go another [ __ ] ball
of this fire and I'll see you
[ __ ] later on we'll check up on
each other
how would you check out my Uncle John
uncle Joey what's going on before [ __ ]
balls of death and seven [ __ ] stars
pilot to Bombardier pilot to Bombardier
it's a clown out there
nice
and sweat that [ __ ] it's 112 [ __ ]
degrees here but who's on the balcony
with their favorite [ __ ] nephews and
nieces now we should be in the
air-conditioned make it scratching my
balls sniffing my friend is having
somebody rub my [ __ ]
were you [ __ ] from the heat
back around smoking reefer bang for bang
who gives a [ __ ] gets up far
this is it you people think I'm over
here [ __ ]
jumping up with people in a bowl they
like eight people here yes sir
listen cuz my Uncle Joe solo like
Michael Jackson 77 solo you understand
me
like general let him so long that's how
I roll like this BAM sweat from my
[ __ ] Armenian eyebrows look at those
things those things couldn't be any
[ __ ] bush-era that's it that's it
I love you guys have a great weekend
we'll be back Monday night at eight
o'clock I'll be checking in with you
cops up this tomorrow night I'm at the
ice house but to a spot there in a dirty
show and ten o'clock if you're around
say hello tomorrow 9:00 hi Sal Stan
o'clock if you're around we'll come up
with some dirty shitty mufflers
[ __ ] in your heart all that type
of [ __ ] all right I love you [ __ ]
have a great weekend keep the eyes open
if you go out tonight make believe your
habit but not really keep an eye open
you know time go he's gotta like
different [ __ ] people not gonna say
boo I love you cops tough to stay black
don't take [ __ ] from nobody and you know
what they gotta suck your dick it's
Friday they're giving their mama tell
our being the higher will be [ __ ]
little backup stapler